canceled and no we can't get through the  Southwest multiple cancellations you  know a night in the airport a night a  Christmas Eve and a random Hotel the  winter storm caused thousands of  cancellations across Airlines but  transportation secretary Pete Buda judge  says southwest's unique inability to  recover goes beyond the storm's Ripple  effects because what we're seeing right  now from the system and the flights  themselves to the inability to reach  anybody on a customer service phone line  is just completely unacceptable  Southwest CEO Bob Jordan apologized and  blamed the weather for the disruptions  we're the largest airline in 23 of the  top 25 travel markets in the U.S cities  where large numbers of scheduled flights  simultaneously froze as record bitter  cold brought challenges for all Airlines  the storm was forecast for five days  everyone knew  even those not affiliated with Airlines  knew what was coming and Was preparing  Southwest wasn't